what is happening to reject nation it's
Greg Alva here it's John Humphrey over
here so today we're gonna review the
movie jigsaw
alright so we actually caught this movie
on 4dx experience over at CTV cinemas in
Buena Park you guys probably heard us
talk about it before Kyle and I did a
vlog covering the event that they're
having over there this awesome haunted
theatre experience with spooky
decorations some scare some monsters
it's a total blast and therefore DX was
awesome it really did enhance the jigsaw
experience so if we were to recommend
watching jigsaw I would absolutely say
watch it at 40 x over at CTV cinemas be
a part of the trap and today we also
wanted to give a shout out to this new
app that we've been partnered up with
called Stardust Stardust as an app that
allows you to do 30-second reactions for
any film TV show or trailer we just put
up ours for jigsaw if you want to catch
our super short thoughts a lot of your
favorite youtubers that are using it as
well Jeremy Jones the flick pick late to
the party as a whole bunch of youtubers
using it but if we're the first ones to
mention this to you you make sure to use
our link first download it and follow us
Jon did his whole recap of all of the
Saw movies and I'm using it to take
advantage of covering TV shows I'm
watching so if you like the kind of
things that we do here and you want to
see them in a bite size form or if you
just want to get on and upload your own
reactions download Stardust our special
link below and make sure to follow us
first so they know that we sent you and
be sure to send us your Thor reactions
if you are using the app tag us and
Stardust on social media and we might
even use one of those in our upcoming
review for that movie like how we're
gonna use for jigsaw right now take a
look it is a Saw movie it's all it takes
the Saw franchise back to his original
form where it was less about gore and
more about the craftiness of the traps
people are totally panning this movie
and getting it but you know I've loved
the icky feeling that I get watching it
I love the suspense I'm surprised that I
liked it the acting is just what you
would expect sort of made up for it and
the twist
overall if you're a fan of the franchise
this is one that finally makes up for
assault a final chapter there are a
couple surprises what the ending is so
obvious I thought it was
and it's fun he just wanted ways to not
run I have less pornographic over
convoluted crazy bloody October garbage
if you're a go for it make sure to
download and follow us at the real
rejects on Stardust now onto our
full-length jigsaw review saw not the
final chapter it's another chapter the
eighth chapter if you will so in this
movie it's directed by the Spill burg
brothers it's directed by the spirit
brothers who did a film such as
predestination and Daybreakers two films
were pretty well received actually now
they're moving on to this it's been
seven years since the last saw
installment I was pretty interested in
seeing this film when I saw the trailers
I was thought like this looks like saw
might actually be going down a path of
having a little more fun I noticed the
cinematography definitely looked
different it was shot in a much wider
frame ratio so you get a better aspect
ratio when you're watching the film
honestly I got pretty much what I wanted
from the film I didn't really factor in
what people were saying on Rotten
Tomatoes about it I'm like it's a Saw
movie I don't really care what they have
to say I never critical darling not
going into it for that I actually got a
little bit more out of it than than I
expected it to there's not much gore in
the film I mean there's moments there is
they oh they make it count they make it
count
I was never grossed out to the point
where I was like I know you were there
were times where do you definitely were
like oh the pound-for-pound there's not
a ton of gore in this movie but I will
say that during the gory moments they're
pretty gory there's some effects in here
that I was not expecting to see yeah at
one point you see somebody's whole head
has been bisected across the middle and
you just see like jaw and brains and
like I was not expected it's cool it's
gross it's gross but it's not like you
see it happen you just see the body we
had seen that happen then I would have
been engrossed that pound-for-pound in
terms of like screen time gore this
isn't like the previous Saw movies where
you know it's like all the tendon cut
has 30 more seconds of gore it's not
like that kinda this movie's not a Gore
fest so I'll say that to me what I
really the gore account what I really
appreciated about this film is that it's
a mystery film like
davin something that I felt the other
saw movies kind of lacked it's like
there's always a twist I guess there's a
mystery element to it but this was a Saw
movie that actually has you guessing the
whole time basically it's been a long
time since there's been a jigsaw
appearance of any sort so people are
like what's going on is jigsaw actually
back from the dead
how can that be there was a whole
autopsy scene we had the truth will set
you free if there's an apprentice who's
the apprentice who's the one carry on
his work he was the copycat killer yeah
and then there's the detective story in
here as well trying to solve the mystery
I actually really enjoyed it I thought
the mystery element was really well done
and there were times where it was very
questionable at times we were like this
doesn't make sense and it has the act 1
act 2 act 3 structure with the three
structure having the big twist reveal
like we expect in all these Saw movies
and when that twist was done I thought
very clever it was in front of me they
were leaving little clues throughout the
whole time and by the time it's unveiled
it has everything makes sense I thought
it was a really well done twist and one
thing I'll give this film the biggest
credit four out of eight Saw films I
will not say it's the best Saw movie
especially when it has a established
fanbase already I would say it's easily
the most enjoyable to watch it would
probably be the easiest to rewatch it's
probably got the most rewatch of doing
the most out of all of them as I would
say with the other saw films I thought
they were really grim and dour and kind
of gross every time one of them ends I
just feel like icky and in a dark place
so by the time one of those films and by
the time this one was done I actually
said I had fun watching it and I thought
it was actually fun I had never said
that about a single Saw movie and it's
what they said they wanted to do from
the very beginning and you get that
sense that from behind the camera
someone is having a good time with this
no it's not creepy at all there's that
thing where the movie doesn't get overly
zany or overly humorous even though
there are some moments of self-conscious
humor but there are a lot of little
things that happen here and there where
you can tell that you know the people
making it the oral the movie has a grin
inside of it yeah there's a trap that
you see a hints of in the trailer when
there's a couple of people trapped in
this like large pile of grain and then
there's like objects falling down there
in a silo and honestly when that trap
was going down I was
laughing but not in an unintentional way
I was just laughing cuz I was like wow
I'm actually enjoy like having a fun
time with this trap instead of just
being like oh my god this is gross and
one thing I like to which I I'm not sure
how soft fans will respond I've seen
every Saw movie and I personally like
this touch they don't do the crazy hyper
stylized flashes and music video style
of chaotic editing when the traps are
going down if anything they just play
out like a scene which I really
appreciate it it wasn't like how you put
it in the car it wasn't obvious that
they took a bunch of different coverage
on a bunch of different angles and then
they made it work in the editing room
you could tell it was thought out how
they were gonna put this together when
they were actually filming it the cast
is good I mean there's a really good the
writing of the dialogue isn't always up
to snuff but there are a lot of times
where it is and this is the first saw
movie I can really think of where most
of the people involved in the actual
trap are not completely unlikable yeah
and I don't just hate them I would say
that there's no one in this movie I
loved there's not a single character
always bragging I love this character
and I really hope they don't die I never
felt that way at the same time though I
was never like god I can't stand these
characters I can't wait for all of them
to die yeah and there there are certain
Saw movies that are hurt by that and
this made a really nice effort to kind
of allow these piata to talk and
interact in the situations instead of
just yelling at each other until
someone's dead yeah you know and it
doesn't have all the cliches of you know
someone wakes up in a trap it took away
a lot of cliches I would get on my
nerves after seeing so many saw
installments well yeah this movie takes
into account that we all know the
conceit by now the characters know the
conceit by now there this is all about
catching a copycat killer it doesn't
waste a lot of time with that stuff and
so it feels a bit more fresh because of
that and it doesn't even do the whole
recap of the entire film montage that
all the other saws do either you know it
kind of gives you the credit for paying
attention and keeping it going and there
are some moments of flat you know
exposition dialogue yeah and yeah yeah
like two-thirds of the way through there
are some times when you're cutting back
and forth between multiple plot lines
where it does start to feel a little bit
like a mess but
overall it comes back together and I
thought it was nice that they were able
to take me from a place of sitting there
watching and going how is this possible
and then by the end I'm like all done
yeah nice nothing I mean don't get me
wrong there are some definite cons in
the film there's this whole side plot
that they have with the assistant
surgeon yeah the coroner's and I won't
go I won't give away what the site what
the side plot is the whole time I was
watching I was like this is so
unnecessary
and I felt it I you could see what the
directors are trying to do with it
trying to give you like make you think
about it and it would be a spoiler if I
said what it was about I just knew it
was a waste of time by then I was
watching it and by the time film quits
I'm like yep it was always stuck inside
track and I didn't like what they were
trying to do with it in one of the
things with the saw traps is all these
people are specifically chosen victims
who have details on their background
that are kind of kept secret that
whoever jigsaw or jigsaw copycat is
knows the details of what's really going
on you put it best like how is jigsaw
omnipresent how does he know so many
details to things that haven't been
released or you would have to have been
there to know the details of certain
things I feel like part of the
suspension of disbelief with any of the
saws is sort of getting past the
orchestrations because you know this is
a lot of work for whoever's doing yeah
and a lot of precision and a lot of
planning and timing do I love this film
no I don't love it but do I think it's
pretty enjoyable yeah I thought it was
actually really enjoyable especially for
a guy who's seen every single Saw movie
yeah better or for worse and this one
certainly brightens things up and brings
enough of the old stuff that you're
familiar with and that you love or hate
depending on your feelings about to saw
and it shines it up with some new life a
new sense of tone and a new look yeah
there's a new style of direction that I
really preach there's some damn cool
shots in this movie the visual aesthetic
to the film is arguably the best visual
aesthetic I think you can make an
argument for it being the best visually
looking Saw movie there's sunlight in
this movie it's not some grainy Goffe it
doesn't feel any great yeah it's not as
visually ugly and tonally ugly because
you know not everything is washed out
yeah and that does you know help it feel
a bit fresh and it's more about the
mystery element and less about the gore
element but when the gore is there the
gore is there I I just think that spirit
brothers had a lot more fun making this
film than other installments have I
wouldn't say it's the best saw movie I
might rank it as number three or four to
be honest I think everyone pretty much
agrees that saw one and six or the best
ones in terms of its themes and mood and
mystery elements I think saw one it's
working as horror movies yes exactly I
would say it's a third best Saw movie
but the number one most enjoyable it's
not gonna push you too too hard like I
said you know the traps are relatively
simple this time around they're not you
know but there's a reason for these
amazing Rube Goldberg contraptions yeah
so much like the kind are but they're
not as outlandish as some of the
previous traps but I think there's a lot
of stuff that they dial up in in instead
of that you know that helps this movie a
lot and more importantly they're just
damn good twist that actually made it
worth it to me yeah overall I think if
your ass off fan I imagine you would
probably enjoy this and if you're not a
big fan of the previous films you might
still have fun with this one because it
does kind of alleviate some of the
nastiness of the original series yeah
depends on what you want out of it and
what kind of viewer like it's not great
necessarily but it is really enjoyable
especially around Halloween I really
feel your spirit brothers thought this
one out there are people saying that
they don't do anything different with it
and I I don't agree with that actually
especially when you when you watch the
other ones you're like this looks
different it feels different this first
saw movie not that gory and then the
other ones become a lot more gory as
they keep going and I feel like as the
fan base of saw they've kind of come to
expect gore and at the same time the
same fan bases like the first one did it
the best where didn't rely heavily on
gore so I feel like this film has this
good blend of adding a heavy amount of
mystery element to it and then giving us
gore here and there when it's necessary
and applicable without losing itself in
it and so yeah I think this film was
solid I enjoyed that a lot
at a really good time and I think if
you're a soft fan you'll really enjoy
the hell out of it - what would you rate
it John I would rate it five and a half
bear traps and like six rolls of barbed
wire and a thousand volts of electricity
it's pretty good three out of five
all right reject nation thanks for
watching our review of jigsaw go check
it out check it heading for DX boy ready
let's do G view cinemas and one apart
you can subscribe to the real rejects
please click that notification Bell you
can follow us on social media links in
the description box and also we have a
Halloween sketch coming out on Halloween
so keep a lookout for that maybe it's
linked to a little saw territory oh no
no maybe it's not or maybe it's maybe
that's a twist please make sure to
download the Stardust app and follow us
with our special link in the description
box we are using this app actively been
using it weekly for sure I might even
say daily more like every other day
bottom line were freaking using it so
follow us on it jump on it